there's long been one very very big
problem with Windows laptops the
trackpads
have been bad I mean really really bad
but it's time to take the band-aids off
and put the mouse away windows laptop
makers have been working with Microsoft
to fix the problem in new Windows 10
machines I've been testing this new Dell
XPS 15 for the last week and the
navigation experience is far better Dell
nails one of the essentials space the
glass pad has plenty of room for regular
mousing around and two-finger scrolling
and for once the computer actually
responds to my gestures thanks to a new
precision pad technology and better
Windows drivers
three finger swiping works well and
scrolling is very Swift oh and the rest
of the computer is pretty good too like
tales 13-inch model the 15.6 inch screen
is surrounded by a very thin bezel
making the system closer in size to a
14-inch laptop if not small but it's a
tad shorter than most 15-inch laptops
including apple's retina map of pro the
4k screen is gorgeous but many apps look
pixelated on it since they haven't been
updated for the high resolution screen
and if you care about battery lights
pick the cheaper 1080p version
I got about five-and-a-half hours of
normal use on the 4k screen the 1080p
model should last twice as long Dell
says as a bigger machine the XPS 15
packs some crazy specs my $2,100 model
had a quad-core i7 processor 500
gigabytes of SSD space 16 gigabytes of
RAM and Nvidia graphics I was going to
say that the Dell XPS 15 is now the best
premium Windows machine you can buy then
Microsoft announced the $1,500 surface
book with similar specs stay tuned for
that full review but for now be thankful
that hope is on the way for your faders